joining me now is kentucky senator rand
paul senator i'm going to get to the
thrust of my angle in just a moment
with you but first i need to get your
reaction to this reporting
late today from the new york times the
drone strike that we were told took out
an isis facilitator in afghanistan
actually killed a u.s affiliated aid
worker and nine others including much of
his family
seven children the car that the pentagon
in the white house told us was filled
with explosives explosives that
allegedly caused secondary explosions
it was actually filled with water jugs
according to the new york times
investigation
fox has not independently confirmed this
but there were numerous eyewitnesses on
site that night who did
uh
senator your reaction you know if true
it's
if it true it's it's another sad
instance of just the most incompetent
withdrawal we've ever seen in our
history
but uh yeah we'll wait await the facts
as they come forward but yes uh i'm not
surprised that we are
we saw a bombing that was done to show
that oh we aren't as feckless as it
looked like we were in the withdrawal
and in the end that they may have made a
mistake in it that'll be uh you know one
one more disastrous uh fact after
another so i hope it's not true but if
it is true that's uh you know
devastating and you ought to tell the
truth about it if it is
much easier always to tell the truth
initially but i think it is worth it for
americans to listen back to the
pentagon's initial comments about what
went down the white house
and and the the pentagon all of it this
was just two weeks back
the self-defense strike successfully hit
the target near kabul airport
significant secondary explosions from
the targeted vehicle indicated the
presence of a substantial amount of
explosive
material i will note that in the centcom
statement that they put out yesterday
what they last night i should say
what they noted is that there was also
the explosion there were explosives in
this vehicle that could have led to
additional damage
now these are the same uh i guess intel
reports being fed to
these white house uh staffers and the
pentagon
that are also feeding information about
a potential domestic terror threat next
week at a rally that no one's ever heard
of like i don't trust any of these
people at this point senator which is
terrifying on the 20th anniversary of 9
11.
you know the one thing that we did know
and we did have eyes on that we could
have blown up were all of the
helicopters we left all the planes we
left all the humvees armored personnel
there were a lot of things that could
have been blown up on the way out even
if you hadn't predicted the taliban was
going to take over certainly that
equipment should have been destroyed on
the way out instead an isolated attack
somewhere which may or may not have
killed its intended target but this has
been a long-standing problem with some
of the drone attacks is they may even
sometimes get their target but if they
get 10 or 15 innocent people in the same
neighborhood as the target it ends up
creating antipathy that really may in
the end be worse than the initial strike
yeah it's hard to imagine the new york
times being as friendly as it is to the
biden administration on a friday
afternoon reporting with such
specificity
a drone attack that
in part hit its intended target i don't
think it hit any of its intended target
not with this strike at least but i want
to get back to my angle senator because
again on the on the eve of 9 11
the disgraced uh former fbi official
andrew mccabe
he is focused on a different kind of
terrorist the work of countering
terrorism never stopped the upcoming
rally on the 18th or when a particular
anniversary a significant anniversary
is upon us like the anniversary of 911
any events that could be triggering or
could cause extremists to maybe want to
mark those events with acts of violence
you get focused on those
conflating 911 with some rally that at
least none of the conservatives i know
have ever heard of
yeah i think most of uh what they've
done is to construct
an enemy that needs to be so important
we need to fence around the capitol and
i think that's to
redirect our view away from portland and
seattle and chicago
look even in louisville kentucky we have
more deaths per capita than chicago now
so they're taking us away from
the great problems that we have across
this country and try to redirect it
towards uh something that was obviously
a mistake to uh trespass in the capital
but wasn't uh some sort of civil war
they're trying to make it out to be hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else